so you uh take me back to obviously the
full surface era was crazy uh you had
three great bodies of work hit records
all of that
what was it like running around in
Arizona with DMX and swiss beats in the
early 2000s bro yeah it was
it was dope man it was fun man for
people who don't know Swizz Beatz had
kind of like planted his feet pretty
heavy out in AZ he was a part owner of
like a car dealership a nightclub that's
at the same time DMX is out there uh and
it was a lot of energy out there and I'm
from AZ so I gotta ask because I know
you were out there a lot yeah it was a
lot of energy
um
I liked it I mean I was from Philly man
so you know you have a you've been to
Philly you see I would I have I just
told Ness I've literally just rode a
train through Philly from DC to New York
and
and I was telling him how we stopped in
Chester at like one of the stops and I
looked outside and I was like what the
[__] where are we at right yeah
well if you ever go to Philly I mean
it's some nice Parts but
the majority of the parts is like a big
difference from Arizona so when I got
over there and I seen how people living
how nice it is right definitely how deep
it was and plus I'm out there working on
my music so I got a different type of
reception so I was loving it man Swiss
had the club I was performing there was
lit was turned what was like being
around DMX during that era of x
um because that was like he was like in
the desert with them ATVs heavy man yeah
I actually went back to Arizona too like
um for my third album when I after I
fought the case and I came home I
started working on a new project I went
to Arizona to do that before the
accident and
um that was the like the last time I was
like really around X went to his crib
um bought Dr Benjamin to his house now
Dr Benjamin was in the belly movie with
him preaching to him and all of that so
then I'll bring them to X house and we
all vibing out chilling and um
it was dope man X was in a positive Zone
I was liking how he was I mean carrying
it at that time and one of the memorable
moments is when he showed me this giant
scorpion we was riding past he was on
the four-wheeler we was in the car he
was leading us back out to the road to
leave and then he turned around he said
yo y'all want to see a scorpion and be
like yeah and he took a rock he threw it
down and then like
made the Scorpion tail come off and he
picked it up like this and that poison
was Dripping in me like look look
and
that's that I heard his crib was like
like in Carefree like deep like
yeah and that's how I remembered them
like he was just like he ain't give a
[__] about nothing he was just wild
but good dude so that's your last memory
I mean remember with X and Arizona yeah
busted a scorpion Stinger off and oh
yeah yeah with Dr Ben him and belly and
the whole vibe it was it was it was
super dope yeah man it's crazy because
you've uh you've been a part of some
historical movements in hip-hop bands so
it's dope to kind of see you get this
this Battle Run in you that's like
you're like one of the it Battlers now
and you're kind of like helping carry
the scene now so you know I feel like uh
it's just it's just good to see man for
you how are you adjusting because you've
been through so many eras of this music
[__] like how do you adjust
with the new wave with the a world in
which Tick Tock is a big part of what
breaks and you know there's not a you
you have more of a direct line of
communication with your fans now you
know what I'm saying like like you feel
like you're adjusting to the new era
this [__] like pretty well
yeah I mean I don't gotta adjust I'm
living through it yeah I mean so
and I'm not stuck in my ways like I'm
not stuck in the old ways or the old
form of doing business like I move
where however things are going yeah and
I got the team I got Sons you know what
I mean Sons a son that's 19 a son that's
14 like they like super into technology
and the new waves and what's going on
yeah so they put me on I got a team
myself that I do music with that's all
different ages like you know I mean in
all different places in the life that be
putting me on so that's how I'm able to
stay on top of things and I make sure I
just stay on top of being dope and being
a rapper you got a team of people
that'll figure out how I stay on top of
Technology